这个刚过了一个五一长假
大家感觉怎么样
休息的是不是好一点
然后我感觉我这个五一长假在那躺着
这个胡吃海喝
好像吃胖了好多
我觉得大家应该也是每逢过节胖三斤吧
那么今天的话呢开始就是终于结束了
特别挑战的这个渲染这一趴
那我们这这一趴呢就开始讲我们的动画
那今天这个课件呢虽然比较长啊
但是我个人觉得还是比较好懂
因为动画是蛮直观的
而且也非常的有意思
而且今天这节课的话呢
我会尝试把它最基础的原理给大家讲清楚
所以的话呢动画也是游戏中最重要的一个系统
所以非常值得大家去啊钻进去
看看它里面有意思的东西
那么首先从动画系统
就是说为什么我们要做动画系统
实际上这个人类啊
在很早时代就开始对动物的东西很感兴趣
因为我们观察到的自然界它都是动作嘛
但是呢最早人类的表达方式只能绘画
所以但是你会发现就是在几万年前
就是在岩石上
我们的先辈画的这个东西的时候
它都是动感很足
包括在先祖的陶器中
你会发现他画了一系列人物的动态
而不是只是一个竞争
所以那个时候没有投影的技术
但是我想我们的先祖脑子里面想的
他就是一个动起来的世界
所以我们一直在探索这样的一个方法
那么其实呢直到就是近代
我们人人人类发现一个非常有意思的现象
就是著名的视觉残留的现象
这其实也是现代所有的电视啊
所有的显示的设备的一个基础
理论的一个基础
也就是我们发现就是说当我们看到一个东西
这个影像在我们的眼里面会残留
大概1/24秒
而这个呢就是所有的电影
电视
包括游戏以及游戏动画的一个基础的理论支撑
因为我们没有办法真的实现在这自然界里面
那种连续不断的
可以无限细分的这样的一个动画系统
而这里面的话
那就不得不提
我们早期的一个特别有意思的尝试了
就是这个这个就是叫我们叫西洋景这样的东西
这个东西其实还蛮有意思的
就是以前在大家科学不发达的时候
很多那个我最近看了一部电影
他就讲你们的牧师的话
他就用这种方法
让大家的话呢能看到一个在投影上看到
一个动的东西
你没有说是一个蜡烛或者什么
一个比较亮的一个东西
然后你会在很暗的地方看到一个洞的小人在走
包括那个小时候在纸上画的那个小人的动画
我记得我小时候读书的时候
我是经常在这个我的每一本教科书上
都要画一个故事
就一个两个人在打架
怎么样
这个是我小时候最爱的一种游戏了
那么实际上的话呢
这个其实也就是现代动画的一个基础
那么从最早的就是说
我们的动画的先驱是什么呢
首先是电影行业
可以这么认为
就是说游戏行业的动画的基础的理论
基础的工具都是来自于电影行业
那么从最早的迪士尼动画对吧
2D动画
然后呢
到后面就是说我们在早期的七八十年代的时候
那时候最早的电影里面开始用了一些动画
生生成的这个虚像和实拍的石像合到一起
那报到后面就等到那个就是侏罗纪公园的时候
那我们的计算机
动画技术已经到了一个非常高的高度
那个时候当美国的电影院里面
大家看到的那个就是非常震撼的
那个怪兽的时候
大家都觉得非常的震撼
其实今天我们在游戏中实现了很多
动画的效果的话
实际上实际上的话
我们就在逼逼近这些离线渲染的效果
那包括像阿凡达对吧
达到了一个非常高的高度
我一直在讲
就是当年我看到阿凡达的时候
觉得这确实是我们未来要努力的方向
那么那么这里面呢也要提一个电影
就是那个ZUI
ZUI的话呢
是实际上这是第一部
完全用游戏引擎实时渲染出了动画片
所以我觉得这也是代表了动画的未来的方向
就是以前我们这动画是个离线的东西
而今天呢变成了一个实时的东西
那么这些动画的技术它底层到底是什么呢
其实从最早电影里面讲的话
它其实非常简单
它就是2D的
我一帧帧的手绘对吧
把它绘制出来
然后呢到后来的话呢
大家就发现了
说诶我们可以就是说用那个很多个摄像机拍摄
这个演员的动作
他身上加了很多的marker
就很多的点
然后我通过光学的方法追踪这些点
就能够把人物的动作给给恢复出来
那这里面的话呢
就是前段时间我也蛮喜欢的一部电影
就是那个战斗天使对吧
那个忘了叫什么战斗天使什么
然后的话呢
他就是你们的人物表现得非常的真实
非常的自然
那么它实际上也在用这样的一个动捕的技术
这个技术的话
现在我相信在很多同学看到
那个电影的幕后的时候都能看得到
那这些技术的话
实际上也是我们游戏的动画的一个核心的基础
那接下来呢就来了教了我们讲游戏引擎了对吧
因为今天我们这节课不是讲电影节的动画
怎么做的
我们是讲游戏里怎么怎么做的
但是呢这里面不得不highlight一下
就是我们的老祖宗绝对还是电影行业
那么从最早的
比如说最早期的动画
它其实非常的简单
就是几个几个图片翻来翻去对吧
在这里面我们不得不提两个游戏
一个呢是就是199几年的这个这个波斯王子
大家仔细看这个波斯王子啊
这里面的那个小人
他的动作你看上去是不是特别灵活对吧
实际上他是用一张张图片做出来了
那为什么这些人动作看上去那么的鲜活呢
事实上当时这个程序员他为了做波斯王子
他拍了他的弟弟
让他弟弟模仿了里面所有的动作
然后把里面的人物的动作
在那照片上一张一张的抠下来
做成了这个游戏里的相似
所以在那个时代
波斯王子他的动作确实是非常的自然
你比如看这个小孩子
他一跳一下挂在那个上面的样子
是不是很自然
实际上今天我们虽然讲很高端的这个3D的
基于骨骼的动画技术
但实际上我们追求的这种自然感
还是来自于真实的人类
而人类对这种自然的真实感的话
是非常非常的敏感的
那么另外一个的话呢
我想highlight就是这个doom对吧
那最早这个游戏的话
它看上去是不是像一个3D的游戏
对不对
但实际上这个游戏
它完全是用2D的动画实现的
包括你看到那个墙体所有东西给你的空间感
它实际上是通过图片的变形实现的
而这里面的开枪包括怪物被打倒
实际上是用一组的这个照片
根据你当前的相机角度
它贴上不同的贴片
让你以为你真的在一个3D的空间去渲染
旋转啊
去去去绘制这个东西
这也说明就是人类真的是非常非常的聪明
这也是我们游戏动画的一个鼻祖
那么接下来的话呢也就是进入了3D时代
看我们开始有显卡了
那从最早的比如说像那个就是生化危机的时候
你看到这里面的人物开始有动画了
但那时候动画你会看到有很多穿帮的地方
待会我跟大家解释了为什么会穿帮
因为它只是在动很硬的骨骼
到后面的话呢
我们开始用蒙皮动画
这个时候我们可以像一个真人一样的
这个动画看上去就非常的自然一点
但是呢其实这个动画你现在看的还是觉得很土
那到现在的话
像神海这种越来越真实细腻
就是有既有物理的仿真
又有这个就是啊人物的非常自然的这种动画
那这也是代表了我们现代的游戏
动画的一个高度
所以今天这节课的话呢
我们着重给大家讲的
就是我们现在游戏引擎的这些动画的一个
一些技术
那么讲到这个动画
动画技术在游戏引擎中的话呢
实际上我们不得不说他有很多的挑战
这个和大家想电影行业不太一样
电影行业我们做动画呢
他很多时候你做好了
我就一帧一帧的播放给你就可以了对吧
但是在游戏里面他的第一个挑战是什么呢
因为在游戏中我们并不能预设玩家的行为
所以玩家在游戏中会遇到很多的东西
比如说我突然一开始走着走着
我突然决定要跑对吧
跑的时候我突然一下子
我看到前面有个障碍物要去跳
跳起来之后我觉得有个东西我要抓住
所以其实在游戏的世界里面
他的动画是要和很多game play去互动的
也就是说
我们要这个
就是说要接受很多来自于用户的输入
同时呢我的动画还受制于游戏的整个环境
比如说哎我跑到一半
我撞到一面墙
这个时候我要表现一个被撞到的动画
或者我走着走着
突然一个怪物把我抓起来
或者把我打倒
那这些games play的东西
这些物理的反馈
我怎么能够在我的这个动画系统里面
能及时的反应
表现得非常自然
这就是游戏动画系统里面
它相对于游戏电影来讲的话
它的挑战的地方
那么另外一个的话呢
也就是游戏引擎
我们从渲染那一趴
一直跟大家讲的就是游戏引擎
还有一个很大的挑战是什么呢
所有的东西都是实时的
Everything is real time
就是我想你无论你想了最复杂
最高端的算法
他永远要在1/30秒里面把它烧完
还记住每一个系统
比如说我们前面讲到的绘制对吧
我们现在讲的动画
包括我们的游戏逻辑
我们的物理
我们的AI
这所有的东西都要竞争那个1/30秒
也就是30ms的窗窗口
但是呢现代游戏呢
我们又希望这些啊游戏里的角色
他越越做越新颖
而且呢我们希望场景越来越宏大
这事实上给动画系统造来造成了巨大的挑战
因为它的挑战不仅仅是我们算不过来
还包括什么呢
还包括就是我的动画数据本身非常的大
当我去不停的去取这些数据进行计算对吧
然后这个取来取去
还记得我们在渲染那一趴
讲的就是说当我在内存里面跳来跳去的时候
我的性能也是非常非常低的
所以呢这也是在游戏引擎里面
动画系统的一个很大的挑战
所以今天我们会讲一个就是动画压缩
实际上也在解决这样的一个挑战
那么第三个呢
也就是说
实际上随着现代游戏的这个就是要求
越来越高的话
我们对角色的这种自然感和真实度
要求也是非常的高
其实当我们的动画师在做做动画的时候呢
我们一般会预设一个
比如说你在一个无限延伸那个平面上
去做反复循环的动作
但是真实的在游戏里面的话
你会发现角色他每时每刻都要接受
来自于用户的输入
那他的动作就会变得非常自然
你像那个最右边那个图里面的话
也就是现在在三游戏游戏里面
最火的叫motion matching技术对吧
它是有很多很多动作融合在一起
让你看起来这个角色非常的鲜活
那包括的话呢
这个角色他还要跟环境进行
各种符合物理规则的互动
我们叫physics based animation
还有呢更加的难的是什么呢
就是当我们的相机推得足够近的时候
我们就可以看到角色的脸
那时候我们就会进入人类最敏感的东西
叫做表情
实际上表情直到现在
在计算机那个游戏里面
都是一个非常挑战的东西
你想做的质量很好的话
其实非常的难
这就是动画
我们对realistic的话也在提出越来越高的要求
因为现在大家已经越来越习惯
也就是动啊游戏引擎实现的效果逼近于电影
而且的话呢我们的屏幕也越来越大
从4K降到8K
将来我们的V2
我们就希望有一个非常high fidelity的
这样的一个虚拟的人物站在我们的面前对吧
那么我们讲虚拟人技术的话
其实虚拟人技术里面最核心的
就是它的这个动画技术
好
O
这就是游戏引擎里面动画技术的一个核心挑战
那今天的话呢
所以我们今天这两节课
大概可能我争取三个小时左右吧
那能全部讲完两节课
一个一个一节课
一半小时能够给大家构思一下
就是说动画系统最核心的技术
我们把这个课程呢分成两派
第一趴呢就是今天我们会介绍一些非常基础的
关于动画系统系统的这些技术
也就是说你上完这节课
基本上你能做一个简单的带动画系统的游戏了
那么我们会从什么时候开始开讲呢
可能会让大家有点意外
我们首先会讲2D的动画技术
为什么
因为我们这节课讲的是游戏引擎
对不对
大家不要认为今天的游戏全3D了
其实这个星球上最popular的最赚钱的游戏
很其实是2D游戏
那么其实2D的动画技术
也是一个非常重要的技术
然后呢
接下来我们给大家讲一下3D的动画技术
而在3D动画技术
你们的好了
我们会辟出一个专门的章节
给大家讲的就是蒙皮动画的真正的实施的细节
为什么呢
因为就是说大家提到3D动画呢
其实核心的就是这个蒙皮动画
也就是我们见的最多的游戏里面角色的动画
但是呢蒙皮动画它的原理讲起来非常简单
但是当你钻下去
当你真的开始去写一个游戏引擎
不是只是简单的调用引擎的时候
你会发现这里面有很多的就是基础理论
基础数学的问题
那么我们今天这节课讲的是游戏引擎嘛
所以我会跟大家讲一些真正细节的东西
这些东西是很重要
因为它就是动画是这样
你很多时候你认为你懂了
但是你写的时候
如果你对他那个他的基础知识
掌握的不够扎实的话
你可以写出很多的bug出来
那么第4part呢
就是我们会讲一下动画数据的处理
那今天呢我们讲的是非常简单
但又是非常实用的一个东西
就动画数据是如何压缩的
因为这个也是呃
基本上今天你要如果写个游戏引擎的话
动画数据是一定要压缩的
否则的话它会有很多的问题
那最后呢我们会给大家介绍一下
整个动画真正生产的pipeline
为什么呢
因为当我们去写游戏引擎的时候啊
你不是只是写引擎里面的那些东西
你大概率可能会要写很多
3D max maya的这个插件
就是帮助艺术家把动画
导致你自己的引擎所能接受的这种格式
而这里面的话呢
你实际上是要对艺术家的整个动画
素材和数据生产的流程需要有所了解
所以基本上听完今天第一节课的话
你就能做一个完整的动画的pipeline了
那么第二节课呢
我们会给大家介绍一些
就是相对来讲比较啊高端一点的东西
但这个高端其实也不算是什么啊
就是fancy的技术
应该也属于现代游戏引擎的标配
比如说动画到底是怎么去blending呢
就是刚才我讲的
就是怎么根据我的游戏的操作逻辑
进行各种合理的混合
包括我们会介绍IK技术点
就是说动画和环境进行互动
还有呢就是这个你的整个复杂的animation pipeline
还有呢就是说大家喜闻乐见的就是动画书
叫animation graph
它的设计原理
它有哪些节点
它是怎么怎么运作的
然后最后呢我会跟大家去讲两个
就是说比较有意思的东西
就是说怎么去做人面部的
就是official animation
其实你们会发现就是facial animation
和普通的形体的动画是两套技术体系
两套完全不同的方法论和技术上
那么最后呢会给大家讲一个比较有意思的
就是说诶我做了一个动画
A动画和这个A角色
我把它的形体变一变
比如说我本来是一个人在走路
我能不能把它转移到一个大怪兽的走路上面
那就叫做animation retargeting
那这些技术呢就相对来讲
虽然呃就是说比这一第一节课讲的要难一点
但是呢如果你想做一个
就是说3A级的游戏引擎的话呢
这些也属于入门级的一些技术体系
所以我们动画的两节课的话呢
就会讲一些非常标准的
就是现代游戏性的核心模块
那么其实呢还有就是比较前沿的动物
比如像motion matching这种东西的话
我们可能会把整个课程上完之后
争取在高级课里面跟大家去讲
那么先在这两节课的话
我们把大家对于动画系统的基础一定要打好
那如果你将来想成为一个游戏动画师啊
如果你想成为就是游戏的
这个就是说game play的这种这个designer
那么还有game play的programmer
包括你在想做这个动画方面的这个专家的话
那这节课的内容的话跟你挂相关度会非常的高
那我们就先从这个我们的这个就是2D的动画
开始说下来对吧
那2D动画呢
事实上它也是我们整个游戏引擎动画的鼻祖
那么最标准的就是我们叫做精灵动画
那其实他他的想法就非常的简单
就是我把游戏里的角色
然后呢把它整个动作一帧一帧一帧一帧
每一帧哒哒哒哒哒哒哒
全部把它记下来
然后呢我在游戏中循环播放
是不是就是一个很完美的2D动画
其实我们童年的回忆其实全是这样的
2D的动画
我们不知道大家有没有玩过有一个游戏主机
什么任天堂啊
什么小霸王啊
暴露年龄系列对吧
我不知道在座的同学中
有多少人见到过小霸王的那个机器
那个上面所有的游戏都是这种游戏的欢乐
都是用这个2D动画的技术做出来的
那这里面特别要讲的super maria
我记得我在第一节课
我听大家讲的就是那个时代做游戏和游戏的人
他根本不需要游戏引擎
它们真的非常的聪明
比如像这只小蘑菇的话
当它开始动起来的时候
它实际上就是一张图
它就是把它flipping左右左右
把它flak播放的时候
你就感觉到一个小家伙瞪着眼睛向你走过来
所以那个时候真的是因为资源很少
大家做东西还是非常具有想象力的
那么接下来的话呢
就是说我们随着这个计算机的发展
就像刚才我强调的
像doom的话
他实际上就会意识到说诶
我如果让如何表现这个角色更加生动
我要让她觉得像个3D空间真实的角色的感觉
他实际上就在各个视角去踩了一系列他的动作
然后呢根据你的相机位置
我在播放不同的spirit的动画
这样给你一种很虚拟的这种3D的感觉
实际上我真的也是非常的震惊
就是在那个时代他们就可以做的这么好
因为我入行的时候就是3D
所以我我我我我是当上这节课
我在准备的时候
我才意识到
就是说原来doom是用2D的方法去做出来的
那么其实这样的技术啊
它虽然很古老
但是在现代游戏引擎里面
就算是一个很高端的纯3D的游戏
引游戏或者游戏引擎里面
这个技术并没有完全消耗掉
因为在我们的这个很多游戏中的东西
比如像particle system
我们有一节专门的课给大家讲的就是粒子系统
其实party system
比如说大家看到那种烟和成的爆炸
它爆炸出来的每个离子
那个离子呢它不是一个静态的一张图
它实际上是一个序列帧
就是你可以看到一个烟球
从慢慢的扩散开来的效果
其实在我们的2D的游戏
在特效系统里面还是非常广泛地应用起来的
一个系统
而但是呢我们真正的大量的游戏
也就是大家经常那个氪金对吧
就是什么六先充个648的这种游戏呢
实际上是用了一个更高端的2D动画技术
就是我这里面要着重介绍的就是live two d
当时你真的真的是个非常了不起的一个系统
就是说呃我个人还是蛮喜欢这个技术体系
就是非常简单
但是给艺术家的空间特别大
就是你看右边这个二次元的这个角色
非常的鲜活对吧
他就是用一系列图片通过变形
通过编辑就可以形成
那这个live two d它是怎么用的
我觉得如果同学们你们如果想做卡牌游戏
想做二次元游戏
如果你没有觉得哎呀
我的预算有限
我的时间有限的话
我觉得这一趴的话就是你们最关注的东西了
那么拉土地其实他的想法非常的简单
就是说诶我我把一个角色上面的所有的元素
比如她的头发
她的眼睛
她的眉毛变成一个个的小图源
我把这个图片拼在一起
变成一个大资源放进去
那里面每个图源的话呢
实际上我们通过它的这个旋转放缩
还有呢WARING就变形
WARING呢就是简单来讲
就是你给他套一个框架
你对那个框架各种拉伸的时候
它在每一个就是那个小的框架里的三角形也好
或者四边形好
它会进行一个叫我们叫做反射变换
然后通过这种变化的话
我就能够把它各种元素做出来
让你觉得很鲜活
那么这个听上去是不是诶真的有这么强吗
我一看我以前也觉得他怎么可以做的这么好
包括我们有很多大作啊
就是比如说那个像这种所有的二次元的
这个少女这样的游戏
其实都是用这个技术做的
做的真的让我觉得非常的棒
没有想到
就是就是拥有简单的二级技术就做出来了
那这里面的话呢它的方法其实非常简单
它首先呢会把所有的图源
把它设置设置成各种的深度
然后深度就可以定义
他说哎一会儿出现
一会出现对吧
包括他们之间的层次关系
当它动起来的时候
互相不会乱
不会穿插
然后呢这里面的话呢
他会把每一个就是你的图片元素
生成一个控制网格
在这个网格上呢
你可以随随机的加入你的控制点
当你对那些点进行移动的时候
这个图源也就跟着去变
这个就非常的聪明
也就是说当我比如说一个角色
我开心不开心
我的眉毛一会儿皱一会儿
一会儿那个弯下来笑
其实就用这种简单的技术就能实现了
因为二次元的话
实际上这种表达本身就已经非常的具有表达力
那这个时候那当我就是说怎么去K1个动画呢
实际上你可以想想这么多图源
我一针
我第一个叫k friend
这一帧
我比如说我这一帧这个角色眼睛是闭的对吧
下一帧这个角色眼睛闭了
再头动一下
再下一帧呢
哎我再摇摇头好
我这三针坐在一起
我把它串起来
一就在这k fk fence中间一帧帧过去的时候
你这时候就看到一个非常鲜活的角色出来
所以这就是live to d的原理
这个工具
实际上我认为就是他非常符合艺术家的直觉
而且这也是少有几个
就是说不用非常复杂的理解什么3D呀
变化呀
这个什么那个什么三角形啊
这个这个投影啊
矩阵啊
那么复杂的数学啊
就能做出一个很棒的游戏的
这样的一个一个一个体系
包括像unity unreal
包括我们自己的引擎
我们都会全面的支持live two d
我觉得这个他做的太好了
我真的没有必要再做一遍
而且就是我我还是非常敬佩
就是说因为这个星球上最厉害的游戏
其实是2D游戏
不是3D游戏
3D游戏很多时候它就是技术上非常复杂
他做得非常真实
但是的话呢从游戏性上来讲的话
2D游戏真的是王道
其实如果大家经常做引擎的时候
2D游戏引擎也是一个
很值得大家关注的一个方向
因为实际上有些很前沿的游戏游戏引擎的话
他的2D这一块做的非常的好
而且我们我们也看到一些非常优秀的作品啊
他做的给你的感觉非常的好
就是说这里面其实有很多很有意思的
一些技术在里面好
所以呢但是今天我们的课程的主体
还是要回归到我们的这个104的核心的主题
就是我们要做个3D的对吧
像阿凡达
像一个很棒的3A级游戏的游戏引擎
所以我们同时重点要放回到
我们的3D的动画技术
那首先第一趴呢我给大家快速的构思一下
如果你的游戏是个3D游戏的话
你会用到哪些技术
那首先在讲这个3D动画技术的时候
之前呢
我先给大家介绍一个概念叫degree of freedom
就是自由度的概念对吧
指的就是说一个物体
他在这个就是它有多少个自由度
也就是你可以在多少个维度去变化
包括我前段时间我们在看那个就是很有意思
国内模大厂他出了一个就是VR眼镜啊
是VR眼镜
还是啊对应该是VR眼镜
然后呢它上面有个核心的广告词
叫六D6DOF的这个设计
让我觉得很多消费者可能看了之后就疯掉了
什么叫6DF对吧
那我接下来给大家解释一下什么叫6DOF
其实对于一个缸体来讲的话
它在整个三维空间运动的自由度
就是六个自由度
为什么呢
首先它有平移的三个自由度
就是说你可以把它沿着XYZ3个方向去平移
对不对
那么如果你想象一个小方块的话
就你怎么动
它朝着你的方向永远朝着你
背
对你的方向永远背着你
这就是三个自由度
就是三个degree of freedom
Three dio f
那么但是呢这是个刚体对吧
钢铁还有个能力是什么旋转
其实你会发现它旋转可以沿着三个轴旋转
对不对
我可以沿着X轴
我以X轴为中心绕着它转
我也可以Y轴为中心绕着它转
我也可以Z轴为为中心绕着他转
所以你会发现在空间中的所有的钢铁
但这里面讲的是三维空间啊
它的整个自由度就是3+3
三个就是这个平移三个旋转
所以所谓说的很高端的这个六自由度的VR眼镜
本质上就是你可以在这个世界
你可以这样看
这样看
可以上看下看
that's it就是这样了
所以买东西的时候
还是要学一点引擎的基础知识
因为这样你至少不会被他这种广告词
给给带节奏带走
那么其实我们的整个游戏动画的话
它核心就是基于对自由度的表达
也就是我们去对这缸体的运动的一个表达
那么好
那我们在游戏里面的话呢
我们做这个3D的动画的时候
其实最基础的就是一个
就是基于一个层次结构的一个缸体的一个动画
它其实非常像我们小时候看的那个皮影戏
就是说我们把角色的每个关节对吧
做成一个可动的东西
当我去动它的时候
诶那个角色整个就动起来了
那么实际上这个关节呢
它本身会有一个叫树状结构
所以我们叫做hierarchy
就是一层一层的下来
那么其实从最早的古墓丽影开始的话啊
不不是古墓丽输出那个resident evil的时候
你实际上就可以看到
就是说这些动画的基础
这也是最基础的动画
那个3D的动画系统
但是呢这个女人的话呢
它实际上有一个问题
就是说我把我的这个mesh的每个地方
跟一根骨骼绑定的时候
当你骨骼动的时候
这些啊mesh它彼此会穿插的
对不对
大家想就像我们小时候看皮影戏的时候
它各个关节之间是不会互相穿插穿插
所以呢这个时候就是啊
哦这个是一个大家很少见到的一个技术
叫做provilex animation
就是叫顶点动画
这个技术它可能会注意不到
但实际上你们玩的所有的3A游戏里面
基本上应该都用了这个技术
比如说这边这个旗帜
你看到在游戏中
如果一个旗帜啊
这我们表现的特别好的话
要么他用的是这个物理的动画
要么呢它用的是顶点动画
因为这里面的话
你如果你想表达一个风吹过布料的
这个效果的话
如果放骨骼
你都不知道要放多少根骨骼
但是呢你索性把它每一个顶点就是它的位置
随着时间的变化把它存下来
这个存下来呢我们一般会存两个texture
第一个texture呢它的横向轴就是每一个顶点
顶点123456789十
假设你有1万个顶点
那就1万个
对不对
然后呢接下来呢假设你这个动画是有100帧
那我的数轴就是100帧
我就索性把每个顶点的offset
就是它的平移存下来
但其实顶点一遍的时候
大家会觉得大家就知道它的表面的法向
是不会变
还记得在上一节课里面我讲过
就是说我直接用顶点的位置算法向
有时候会算出问题对吧
那为了有的时候为了效率呢
我们就直接把他那个
就是因为你顶点的位置变了
在那一帧每个顶点的法向我也存下来
基本上这张图呢
一般我们是用物理引擎模拟出来
就是我现在离线的把这东西模拟好
然后呢
我存储成这个这个vertex animation的这个texture
那这样我在引擎中就能够展现出非常真实的
这个旗帜的效果
包括下面这个弹幕也是一个顶点动画
大家想象不到
就是如果我的游戏中的表
表现一个像水流的这种效果的话
假如像这样的效果的话
其实我也是用顶点动画去做的
那么接下来的话呢
也就是说其实哦这是wolf target的
哎呀我我觉得我接下来讲吧
就是这个其实我认为这是两个
就是后面的技术了
那么wolf move animation呢
它其实也是一种也是一种顶点动画
但是呢他跟那个传统顶点动画不太一样
就是说它是一个叫顶点影响权重的东西
那这个东西呢它会就是几种不同的key pose
就是每一个顶点的key frame之间去插值
这个东西在什么地方很有用呢
就是说我们在做人脸的时候
相信很多小伙伴都特别喜欢玩
游戏里面的捏脸系统对吧
我我我
我一直认为很多游戏
它的捏脸系统就是游戏的本体
大家拿到一个游戏的话
愿意花三四个小时去捏个脸
捏个脸
那么其实为什么
我可以一会儿这个人是个蒜头鼻
一会儿是个高天高尖鼻对吧
大家会觉得我是不是可以通过啊
你们买一根骨骼把它捏一捏
算放一放
是的确实可以这样
但是呢你会发现当你的这种变形过大的时候
那个脸上的那些五官看上去就不自然了
而那个时候呢
实际上我们很多时候是在各个不同的模
f target的时间来进行插值
我们在下一节课讲这个FISHANIMATION的时候
会给大家详细讲
而我们这节课呢非常重点的给大家讲的
就是就是就是3D的skin animation
就是蒙皮动画
为什么呢
因为我们在游戏中最多出现的对象是什么
是人啊
动物啊
我们人和动物最大的特点是什么呢
就是说诶我们表面有一层皮肤对吧
它不会当随着我的身体动的时候
我的皮肤之间会自我穿插
但是呢我里面其实是一个缸体的骨骼
那为什么就是说当我的缸体骨骼在驱动的时候
那么我的蒙皮也跟着动
看上去那么自然呢
实际上他一个核心的思想
就是说我每一个地
每很多每个顶点它受它影响的不止一个骨骼
而是多根骨骼在一起同时作用
这样的话我能保证
就是说当这个对象运动的时候
它是一个水密性的
叫watertight
就是他不会互相穿插
那么它比早期的那种钢铁的skeleton
动画的话呢
要做的更好
这也是就是说我们现代游戏引擎
最常见的这个动画模型
那么其实呢就是说如果我们知道了
3D的这个就是蒙皮动画的话呢
这里面就断开一笔
就是说其实这个技术呢在2D动画里面
现在也有很多人在用
为什么呢
因为它也是一样的问题
就是如果你只是用谷歌去驱动
一个个的小图片运动的话
那这些图片之间彼此肯定会有穿插
对不对
你看上去就像这个所有的角色
看起来就像机器机器人一样
但是呢其实你用同样的原理
把2D的这个这个角色
也用磨皮动画的方法来做的话
你能看到这个人动的时候
他整个身体和相对自然的去去变形
所以呢它的技术的原理是一致的
所以说也就是说我们今天在3D的这里面讲的
所有的数学运算
在2D里面也是完全起作用的
那么最后一种的动画形式呢
就是physics based animation
这个也相对来讲就比较难了
比如说我们怎么去这个这个角色
他一旦受受击了
或者他死亡的时候
它就会进入一个我们叫做ragdoll rock door的
中文叫做布娃娃系统对吧
我相信很多同学都听过
那么而且早期的时候
布娃系统把人做的跟沙袋一样
但现在的话呢不想做的
就是说
他既有一部分设计师设计的这种animation的感觉
又有整个人摔在地上的感觉
那么还有呢就是说物理的模拟
它物理模拟的动画最用的最多的地方在哪里呢
就是我们的医疗
我相信大家现在很多小伙伴去玩游戏的时候
你们会非常在意这个医疗这个角色身上的衣料
表达的好不好
但是医疗模拟其实是游戏
动画或者游戏物理里面最难的一个东西
包括像流体的木那个模拟
那么最后一个呢也是我们在下节课会讲的
就是IK
就是说诶我怎么样的保证我手永远能抓到一点
IK的全称叫啊反向动力学
就中文叫反向动力学
它指的意思是什么呢
指的意思就是说我给定一个指定点
我的身身体就是这个角色该怎么运动
看上去才最自然
这件事情讲起来很简单
就比如说我在你面前放个苹果
你去抓它这个东西我是不需要训练你的
你天然就会了
对不对
但是在游戏里面如何让这个动作整个一气呵成
实际上是非常非常复杂的
但大家会觉得这很奇怪
为什么电脑会比人笨
但是你仔细观察一下
你看看小朋友
当他在只有0~6个月的时候
你在他面前放个东西
它其实是抓不住的
他要练习练习很久
才能够准确的一下子抓到苹果
所以我们人的话
我一直认为是用DEPING的方法
深度学习方法
经过了长达就是以年为单位的训练
终于练就了那种准确的抓取能力
但今天的话呢我们在游戏里面的话
用什么算法也能模拟出人的这种聪明的话
实际上就是IK这个系统干的事情
所以physics based animation的话呢
实际上也是动画非常重要的一个
一个一个一个分支方向
那基本上呢就是说呃animation
你在run time就是这些方法
那另外一个更重要也是我们讲的就是animation
Creation
就是如何去创造animation
对吧
你那么传统的方法有两种
一种就是说我在编辑器里面有我们的动画师
手K动画
我们经常叫手K动画
K的意思是什么呢
叫k free
就是我我我是通过一个月的K分K这个动画
待会后面我跟大家详细的讲
那还有就是motion capture对吧
就是动捕
动捕的话
现在基本上无论在电影还是游戏中
用的已经是非常非常的广泛了
好那接下来的话呢我们将进入这节课的话呢
真正就是比较核心的
也是数学比较密集的这个爬
就说我们知道了就是蒙皮动画这个需求
那这个蒙皮动画到底是怎么做的
其实我们顺便把整个动画给大家讲清楚
那首先的话呢我们来跟他讲
就是如何给你一个一个一个一个模型
我们叫做一个mesh
你是如何让它动起来的
其实讲起来呢他就五步非常简单
第一个呢我们先做一个模型
也也就是一个max在他的bounding pose对吧
那么第二个的话呢我们去做一个骨骼
这个骨骼呢就跟人类的骨骼一样
它就内嵌在我们的皮肤之下对吧
那么他跟这个这个这个mesh的样子
正好是可以这个align到一起去的
然后呢这个时候我们给它刷上它的蒙皮
对啊
这个具体怎么刷
大家不用管
就是我们刷上那个蒙皮了
就是给每个顶点说哎你该受哪个骨骼的影响
哪个骨骼对你的影响大一点
哪个骨骼对你影响小一点
听上去也很直觉对吧
第三个就是诶我们的animator
就开始让这个骨骼动起来了
那你这些顶点不是被我刷了蒙皮了吗
他姐也就也就跟着动了
对不对
其实你想蒙皮动画的原理
是不是就这个原理非常的简单
但是呢
如果你真的开始动手去写这个代码的时候
你看到的情况大部分时候是这样的
就是你看到那个骨骼诶真的在动了
但是那个角色他就一直傻站在这
或者是整个角色冻就冻飞掉了
其实大家在写这个动画系统的时候
特别是如果这些数学公式没有完全推倒
对的时候
很多时候我们经常讲就把模型给写炸掉了
就是你本来这个角色好好的放在这儿
你一旦动画你写上去的时候
一般动画我们会在SHADER里面去做
vertex shader里面就是每个顶点要去计算
经常有一个公式算错了
或者一个矩阵放错了之后
这个模型直接就炸开来了
所以的话呢
这个地方
为什么我们这节课真正的主体
会把这个地方讲清楚呢
因为这就是一切动画系统的foundation
你把这个就是skinning的
就是蒙皮动画的这个数学和它的实现
整个搞明白了之后
其实你后面去理解IK啊
理解其他的一些动画的时候
其实难度就不大了
所以的话呢
这也是我们今天特别想跟大家讲明白的
这个这个游戏引擎的基础好
那在讲蒙平的话之前的话呢
首先要跟大家讲三个空间
因为你的所有的计算就是在动画系统的计算
他都是在各自的空间里面的这个东西提上去
是不是有点抽象对吧
我们的空间不是很明确吗
我的面前放着就是XYZ对吧
这个东西叫什么呢
这个我们叫做worst space
世界坐标系对吧
在游戏里面我们会建立坐标系
就像我在上一节课讲渲染的时候
我跟大家讲过
就是说在世界坐标系里面的话
我们可以做的非常非常大
可以到一个整个太阳系的距离对吧
但是的话呢对于每一个我的角色来讲的话
实际上我有一个什么坐标系呢
是我自己的坐标系
那大家讲这个时候是不是就表示local坐标系呢
对不对
哎不对
这个地方我们叫什么呢
叫做模型坐标系
也就是以我自己为中心的
比如说我站在这儿
我面前的这样的一个比如说两立方米的空间
它所定义的样子是我的local space
那么我的model space啊
我自己都被带跑了
那我的模型坐标系和世界坐标系是什么关系呢
大家记住它不是一个简单的诶平移的关系啊
因为比如说我的朝向可能会变
对不对
我的整个人可能会这样仰过来对吧
假设你踩在地球表面上
整个宇宙的坐标系的话
它是XYZ
但是你在地球的
比如说45度和南极北极
你的人的朝向是不是都发生变化
当然我只是开个玩笑
一般我们永远会认为我们是头朝上去
站在这儿呢对吧
所以的话呢
其实从世界坐标系到我的模型坐标系
就发生了一个很大的
就是它就有了刚才教大教大家的那个东西
叫DOF
大家还记得吗
自由度对吧
其实有六个自由度的变化
就是我可能会发生平移
XYZ我还会发生什么呢
旋转对吧
我沿着X轴Y轴Z轴去旋转
这样能定义我一个唯一的一个空间的
这样的一个一个姿态
讲到这儿已经很晕了
对不对
但是呢前面在rendering的时候
其实我们也讲了这个概念
就是说你怎么从世界坐标系与模型坐标系变化
然后呢再进行投影对吧
其实讲的就是这个道理
但是呢做动画的时候有一个东西是在模型之上
还有个坐标系是什么呢
我们叫做local坐标系
这个是有点抽象了
它叫局部坐标系
它指的是什么呢
就是我们在动画里面每一根骨骼
大家想我们的骨骼不是一根一根
一根一根上来嘛对吧
每一根骨骼它自己会发生什么呢
会发生这个平移对吧
会发生旋转
那么它相对于你的模型坐标系
是不是又发生变化了
而且这个事情很讨厌的地方是什么呢
就是每一个骨骼它的这个标价
它的这个坐标系都是不一样的
也就是说当我想知道
比如说我们举个例子
比如说我们有个朝向是这个坐标
当你在这个在它的根部
一路往他的手指尖去传递的时候
这个方向就可能发生很大的改变
比如说我现在的手掌的朝向
实际上是由我这个坐标系
这个坐标系
这个坐标系到这个坐标系
比如整个一起形成的
它就一个一个传递过去
那我的整个动画顺序的表达
实际上很多时候我待会给大家解释
就是实际上是在局部坐标系的
就是local坐标系的
而你把logo图标是一路从它的根节点积分上来
就是累累累算上来
你才能算成他的模型坐标系
你把模型坐标系考虑到这个角色
他自身站的位置和它的旋转
你才能把它变成世界坐标系
你只有把它变到世界坐标系的时候
这个角色才会被渲染
所以这三个坐标系的话
是你我们在做动画系统之前
一定要搞得非常清楚的一个一个体系
那这个时候我们理解了三个坐标系的概念
我们就开始给这个角色构建它的骨骼了
那么其实骨骼呢大家可以想就是在角色中
骨骼我们可以任意的去构建
对不对
但是在游戏的这个这个实践中的话呢
其实我们不会
我们一般对于比如说这个人类人形的物体
我们一般叫做这个BPD对吧
就是两足生物
我们会构建这样的一个
跟人类的骨骼非常接近的这样一个骨骼结构
对不对
那么在这个骨骼结构里面啊
大家一定要记住
有个点就是它的起点在哪里
我们讲的是个树状结构对吧
大家想想这个缺点在哪里呢
其实一般是在人的胯部
我们叫做papers
就是你的脊椎的最后一根骨头
那个地方我们叫papers
因为那个点出去之后呢
你会发现它向下就可以分化出你的两条腿
向上就是你的脊椎
脊椎决定你的身体是公的还是直的
对不对
然后呢到你的肩膀一展开诶
它就变成两只手
所以它的中心点是在那个PIA
就是那个脊椎尾椎骨那个地方
但是呢我们有时候会做一个root放在那边
那么其实这个结构呢对于很多啊
游戏里面大部分应用就是够的
但是游戏里面我们还要做什么
我们要做很多可爱的小动物对吧
小动物它就很讨厌了
因为小动物是趴在地上的
它叫什么呢
我们叫QUAL派的四足动物
那四足动物的骨架它就又不一样
那为什么我们要把它定义成这种标准的骨骼呢
因为当我们去生产动画资源的时候
特别是当你去做motion caption的时候啊
包括资源的生产的时候
我们不太可能去生产那么多不一样的资源
如果你的骨骼就这个基础结构啊老是在变的话
其实动画师他是很难做的
因为它有大量的资源库
如果你的骨骼拓扑老是在变
你一会儿以脚趾头为起点
一会儿以脑袋为起点对吧
那这些动画资源之间就很难复用
所以的话呢这个技术结构也是我们这个行业
约定俗成的这样的一个结构
那在这里面的话呢
我们给大家clarify个概念
这个概念其实特别容易混淆
包括我们在游戏里面
包括我自己讲的时候
也会经常讲说骨骼
骨骼骨骼
我们用骨骼构建了
这个这个这个这个这个skeleton
就是股价对不对
skeleton英文的意思就是骨架的意思
但实际上呢在游戏引擎里面
我们并不是真正表达的是五个
我们表达的是什么呢
是joint
就是关节
也就是说实际上我们存储的
比如说是这个肘关节的数据
因为你肘关节前面连了个缸体的骨骼
所以当你的肘关节发生旋转变化的时候
或者发生偏移平移的时候
你的这个骨骼也会跟着动
但是我们并不会直接存储骨骼的数据
那我这个肘关节的下一个子节点
就是下一个那个树状的节点是什么
是我的肘关节
对不对啊
这个这个手这个手腕关节
那这个手腕关节前面就控制了我的手掌
所以实际上在游戏引擎里面我们听到了叫骨骼
骨骼的东西
它实际上是joint
是关节
两个关节之间定义了一个叫做这个这个骨头
但是呢没关系
大家在看
无论是游戏引擎的代码
包括你自己写的时候
你真的把它写成蹦也没有关系
但是这里面的话呢
我想从数学上跟大家把它定义清楚
其实就是说joint呢它本身是有很多的自由度的
但是呢BM它本身是没有的
因为BM是有两个join的
联合在一起定义出来的
而且你想啊
为什么说我们存的是join
不是BN
因为joint它是个刚体对吧
它不会被twist
但是呢你想我的骨骼啊
其实像这边的肌肉
我们是可以被twist
为什么呢
假设骨骼不是个钢铁啊
因为我这边的这个骨骼
这个这个joint在这个地方对吧
这个哎那个这个肘这个地方
这个地方是另外一个一个一个joint
但我这两个join可以这样转
那这个就是这个小B这个地方
它实际上是被扭曲的
对不对
在skinny动画里面我们也会看到这种扭曲
所以的话这就是BM的表达的
它的不严谨性就在这个地方好
其实呢在游戏中我们构建一个骨骼的时候呢
除了我们讲人正常的要的这些骨骼之外呢
实际上我们还会加很多很奇怪的骨骼
这个这也是因为
我们今天要教大家做游戏引擎嘛
一般在游戏引擎里面会加很多很奇怪的
额外的骨骼
最最恐怖的时候
我们一个标准骨骼可能也就100多个左右吧
但是呢我要考虑到这个人脸
我要做很多很细致的表情
我可能又要加七八十个甚至到100个骨骼
很多的细节
这眼睛眉毛的运动啊
比如说大家经常看到眼球的运动啊
我们下节课会讲
他都是用骨骼去驱动的
然后呢游戏动画对这个人有很多的变形
比如说我们会要给他做个大翅膀对吧
大家想做的那种斗篷
还有这个我手上拿的这个武器对吧
各种各样的变形
这些骨骼呢
实际上都会加到这个角色的标准骨骼上面
所以当我们想做一个游戏引擎的时候呢
一般首先第一步就要定义一个标准角色的
这个叫标准组合是多少
这个也是我们的ta团队就是技术
美术团队和技术团队最核心的要确定的东西
那么这里面就讲了
比如说我手上拿了个大斧
那么我的武器实际上是有个叫武器mt骨骼
也就是我手上为了拿了个巨剑
还是拿个大斧
实际上它是mount到你手上一个叫weapon
这个这个这个这个这个joint上面的
然后这个时候你看到这个
好像看着像两只手拿的武器
但一般来讲呢
很多动画师他是把这个武器单一的绑在手上的
那跟武器骨骼上的
一般我们都是角色用右手拿武器嘛对吧
就是右手骨骼
所以呢
其实包括人骑乘在一个这个这个生物上面
它会有一个骑乘的这个joint这样一个骨骼点
那么就是说刚才也提到了
就是说我们虽然说很多股价啊
它实际上都是从这个就是尾椎这个地方
叫PVZ开始
但是在真正的游戏引擎里面呢
我们一般会定义一个叫root的骨骼
root格一般会放定在比如说以人形为例啊
我们会定义它它两脚中间
那为什么这个我要放钉在这呢
大家想想看
比如说我们在游戏里面
表达一个角色的移速对吧
或者他跳起来了
那你比如说我说这个人的离地高度是0.5米
如果你在这个就是说以PVS那个骨骼来存的话
当这个人蹲在那
或者说在那跳起来的时候
或者或者站起来
它的离地高度都会变对吧
但是我们关心的离地高度一般指的是它的角
所以呢那个root的骨骼呢反而更加的自然
就是说当我们去决定一个角色的移速啊
他跳起来的高度的时候
我们一般从他root开始
这就像什么呢
大家喜欢玩手办
对不对
你们无论那个手办摆出各种各样很漂亮的姿势
你发现没有手办
它下面总有一根支架
那根骨骼
那根骨骼是插到你的那个台座上面的
对不对
那个台座你可以在你的桌子上移来移去
而那个支架插下来的就是我们的root骨骼
而这个骨骼呢其实非常的重要
那么另外一个呢很重要的骨骼是什么呢
就这个就这是一个给大家演示的一个问题了
就是说假设我们一个表达像四肢动物的话
那么他的PVS骨骼就是它的尾椎骨骼在哪里
他的入睡在哪里
这个地方呢其实非常有意思
大家想象一下
我们一个演员如果想让他扮演一匹小马的话
那他的尾椎在哪里呢
是不是正好在马的屁股那边
所以呢其实动画师一般会把他的PVS那个骨骼
放到他的尾椎那个地方
但是他的root呢
诶他就很聪明的放到那个母马的肚子下面
为什么呢
因为我现在要表达一个码的位置的时候
我一般都会以它的中心点那个位置来表达
所以这个地方其实很有意思
就是你会发现
当这些骨骼结构在行业里面约定俗成的时候
它还有它很深的一个道理在里面
就是方便让我们对它的位置的表达
就非常的准确好
那么就是这里面也讲了一个很重要的概念
就是说我们大家还记得
我们在前面在讲这个就是game play系统的时候
讲到那个object之间是有父子关系的
对不对
但为什么我们需要有父子关系呢
因为在游戏中啊
有很多动画
很多角色之间的行为是绑定的
所以经典的就是人骑在马上
那这个东西是怎么做的呢
实际上人是播放人的动画
马是播放马的动画
我怎么让他的动画一致呢
我在人的上面会有一个叫mt的这个joint
这个这个这个这个关节在马的马鞍那个位置
我们有也有一个mt的那个那个那个joint
这两个joint它就重合在一起
这个重合记住啊
不是一个简单的XYZ空间的重合
还有什么呢
它的旋转重合
也就是说你可想象他那个坐标系
它的轴是整个对接在一起的
大家想象一个卡槽
它不是一个简单的一个点连接
点连接只是位置重合
它是连你的朝向
就是当马前倾的时候
你人要跟着前倾
马后仰的时候
你要跟着后仰
这样的完美的卡在一起
这就实现了我们的BOUNDANIMATION
其实这个BOUNDANIMATION的话
对于角色来讲非常的重要
我们有大量的叫做载具
比如说大家经常在游戏中看到的
比如说我开汽车
对不对
那角色是怎么开汽车呢
实际上就是你看到角色展开了一系列很花哨的
比如说拉开车门翻身跳进车里面
你看着很厉害吧
但是他总有那一帧诶
这个角色的屁股
就绑死在那个汽车的某一个座椅上了
然后呢这个时候车怎么动人呢
就跟着动了
所以这其实就是游戏引擎里面
如何实现这个绑定动画的
而这个呢也是引擎必须要实现这个功能
它一般会和跟play系统连接得非常的近
所以动画为什么我讲
就是说
如果大家想做这个game play的这个程序开发的话
一定要理解动画系统
因为这是他两个是不可分加的紧密关联的
这里面的讲一个就是在工业上
我们一个常见的一个现象
就是说其实在早期的时候
我们在做游戏引擎的时候呢
我们会把角色的骨骼
角色和骨骼的绑定
我们用什么呢
我们叫TPOS
我相信大家能想到TPOS很自然对吧
整个人双臂张开
对不对
但是呢随着现在的商业游戏的发展呢
大家逐渐会发现这个t pose有问题
就是这个角色的这个肩膀这个地方诶
他其实是被挤压的
比如说想象一下
我要做一个比较复杂的这个角色
这边的肩胛的这种展开啊
变形的动作的时候
那你这边的精度其实就是不够
所以在现在3A游戏中的话呢
我们一般越来越多的用我们叫做apples
就是整个人站的相对自然一点
那这个地方就会给它相对高的这样的一个精度
这个呢实际上也是行业里面一个一个实践
那么其实呢当我有了这样的一个骨骼
我有了这个mesh之后
实际上当我去动这个骨骼的时候
骨骼它比如说表达走
当我把这个动作做出来之后
这一个静止的状态叫什么呢
我们叫做一个pose
Pose
这个词大家很熟吧
就是什么就是姿势吗
姿态
比如说你拍照片的时候
我说你摆个pose对
就是你在动画中
我们一个pose指的就是一针你的镜在这
或者你手举在这儿
这就叫一个一个pose
那我们把很多的pose连到一起的时候呢
我们就会形成一个动画对吧
但是呢这里面在post里面呢
我们要讲一个细节哦
我这个PPT上少了一行
就是说其实我们在真正的表达一个动画的
这个pose的时候呢
它是有九个自由度的
刚才我讲了一个钢铁的运动
不是只有旋转啊
只有平移和旋转嘛
但实际上呢在真正做动画的时候
我们还有一个叫skill放缩
放缩在比如说很多动画里面其实是非常有用的
比如说我去做人脸的变形啊
我去做一些
比如说一些角色的弹性的一些变化的时候
我们需要用到放缩
这个呢其实比较简单
我们以后面再讲
接下来这一趴就是我们今天这节课呢
相对来讲比较硬核的部分
就是真正就是他的数学是什么
在理解这个动画之前啊
你们会发现
就是说
如果我们的动画适用各个关键点表达的时候
你们想我们手上的关节做得最多的运动是什么
是旋转对吧
这个旋转呢它很难
它就是它有很多的自由度
它不是一个简单的
就是说哎一个轴旋转
它有很多的旋转
我们的我们的人的关节也是设计得非常精巧的
一个一个一个关节
那么如何能在3D空间表达旋转呢
这件事情还真的是不简单的
那么最简单的这个旋转
就是我们想2D空间里面对吧
我们假设重要的一个角度叫西塔
那他呢有两种表达
就是一个是在角度空间里面
我们叫C塔角对吧
还有一种呢
就是我们的大名鼎鼎的笛卡尔坐标系
在这里面我们会告诉你说
它的旋转可以用一个向量表达
就是X等于这个R乘以一个cos的阿尔法对吧
Y等于21个sin阿尔法
这样我就能表达这个一个旋转
当两个宣传
就是我们中学经常学着说诶
当我转完一个阿尔法
我再去转一个贝塔角
那就是扩散
就是阿尔法cos阿尔法加贝塔等于多少呢
我们小时候都学过这个工程的工那个方程是吧
就我记得我在高中的时候
这个学的就是这个三角函数
我相信大家高考啊一定要背这些
应该是中考啊
中考就要背这些东西了
那么我在大学里面我们学了什么
学了线性代数
对不对
我们就可以用线性代数的方法
把它的旋转表达表达成一个2×2的矩阵
大家看下面那个矩阵就是哎
它的横轴是cos c的负sin theta对吧
第二第二排就是那个什么sin theta
Cos theta
然后呢我把任何一个向量XY放进去
我乘上它
它就能旋转
这个是什么呢
这就是二维空间的旋转矩阵
非常的elegant
非常的美
很好看
但是呢这件事情呢
到了三维之后就会变得复杂了
首先三维空间它的旋转
因为在二维空间大家看啊
它的旋转的轴只有一个
就是绕着它的中心点
对不对
在三维空间的话
它不是轴变成两个
而是一下子变成了三个
你可以要绕着X轴做一个旋转对吧
你也可以绕着Y轴做个旋转
你也可以绕着Z轴去做个旋转
实际上呢更难的是什么呢
你可以绕着任意轴去旋转
因为没有人
没有谁规定说我一个东西只能绕着一个特定的
就是跟坐标对齐的access align的方向去旋转
那这个就表达起来就很麻烦了
但是呢数学家证明了
就是说你在这个空间上的任何一个旋转
我可以用这三个轴的旋转把你叠加出来
那这里面有一个非常重要的一个点
就是说那假设我沿着这个轴依依次沿着X轴
Y轴
Z轴旋转
我沿着每个轴转的这个C塔
那阿尔法贝塔伽马的角度
其实呢我们就可以算出很多个
就是3×3的矩阵
那么你注意就是说如果我只沿着X轴群呢
你会发现这个旋转矩阵里面的很多项它都是零
对吧
它其实真正有效的是你们的2×2
四个四个因子
其他的那个一和000都是配平的
这个公式大家自己可以推一下
其实非常的简单
然后呢你就可以把这个旋转
这样的话
当我沿着X轴转一个阿尔法角度
沿着Y轴转一个贝塔角度
沿着Z轴线个那个伽马角度的话
那你把这三个矩阵垒成在一起
就得到下面的那个形式
那个矩阵看上去很复杂
但计算机写起来是很简单的
然后呢
你把任何一个空间上的那个那个点
或者是方向XYZ带进去的话
你就能算出来它的沿着这三个旋转之后
它的样子
这就是一个典型的什么呢
我们叫做欧拉欧拉角
欧拉角的话
我相信大家应该在高中的立体几何里面
或者解析几何
你应该学过这个概念对吧
欧拉角欧拉角也是一个很早期的
很经典的一个对三维空间旋转的这个表达
那么欧拉角这个东西啊
实际上是非常重要的一个东西
比如说你们在这个玩所有的空战模拟游戏
包括你们去玩那个比如说航海游戏
或者说你们真的在开一个游艇
或者开一个飞机的时候
你会知道有个概念叫鸭肉peach对吧
ya呢就是这个航向角对吧
我们一般传统的用那个FI来表达
那么那个peach呢我们叫做攻角
它指的是飞机在气动力的时候
哎我的这个对空气的攻角
那么就是大家peach这个词
就是这个网上进攻嘛意思
那么就是比如说飞机失速对吧
他就是个这个屁是角太大导致的这个动力骤减
让飞机在空中就解体了对吧
那roll是什么呢
诶这个飞机这样自己的这个就是往左啊啊腰啊
这样摇摆
就我这样模拟一下
这个很笨拙
但是基本上能表达这个鸭肉皮吃
其实鸭肉peach呢
它就是一种欧拉角的另外一种话术的表达
它也是其实你可以认为就是现在的导航啊
航空器啊
都是用这个很基础的概念
就是这个这个
比如说你们要做一个vo vehicle系统
就载具系统
或者是这个就是那个空战模拟系统
这是你最核心的几个概念好
包括我们做气动力模拟的时候
我们也要用这个压轴皮尺这个概念在里面
那也是欧拉角的一个一个一个典型案例
那么欧拉角呢其实它是有问题的
欧拉角最大的一个挑战是什么呢
之一不能讲的最大的挑战它是有很多问题
我们先讲一个
我自己认为我最讨厌的问题是什么
就是你对它的计算是严格的
那个叫all the dependency
就是说顺序依赖的
就刚才我讲的就是说它沿着X轴转阿尔法
沿着Y轴转贝塔角
沿着Z轴转那个伽马角对吧
阿尔法贝塔伽马
但是的话呢你去apply
这个运算的顺序不一样的话
其实你得出的角度是不一样的
大家可以想象我们在里面画了一个图
比如说我先沿着这个
这个就是说X轴转90度对吧
我在沿着这个就是说Z轴转90度就转出来的
结果和你反过来转的话
它的结果是完全不一样对吧
这就是三维空间的复杂度
你就会发现就是说在二维上面没有这个问题
二维因为你只有一个度
只有零就好了
这三维你有三个度
这三个度之间的话
它的旋转结果是完全是如果你的顺序错了
它的结果完全不一样
所以说当我们在用欧拉角的时候
一定要约定这个旋转顺序
就是必须是先沿X轴
再沿Y轴
等于ZZ轴
否则整个顺序就是乱的
那么其实这个欧拉角这个东西啊
在我们的实践中
最有一个最贴近的一个实用价值的东西
就是万向节
万向节其实是非常符合人类对空间旋转
感知的一种表达
那么这里面的话呢
就比如说在现代游戏引擎里面
其实我们让艺术家来表达旋转的时候
用的全是这个万向节的这个方法
也是个欧拉角
那万元节这个东西它为什么非常有用呢
我给大家举一个
就是大家可能注意不到的东西啊
我们那个大家拍摄像的时候
有一种叫机头像机头架对吧
就是那个相机放在这
无论你怎么动
他那个朝向永远是对着那个屏幕的方向
这个东西它用的其实就是个万向节的技术
就有三个自由度的旋转
永远保证它的朝向
包括大家喜欢飞的那个无人机
比如大疆无人机
它那个机头
你的飞机飞的时候其实有很多抖动啊
或者这个方向朝
但是你会发现你的画面总是很稳定
对不对
包括我们现在叫什么微云台啊
这种技术
它实际上里面用的也是一个变了形的
这个万向节
保持这个方向就非常的稳定
那么另外一个呢也是一个非常重要的应用
是什么呢
陀螺仪
请大家想象一下
就是在没有GPS导航的时代
我们一个导弹打出去
它是怎么样的不偏航的呢
实际上这里面呢
它有一个高速的旋转的一个陀螺
他这个陀螺呢因为它的惯性的原理
它始终指向一个方向
对不对
但是呢你这个这个导弹它身体它会这样
一会儿上一会儿左
一会儿右
对不对
他怎么能保证那个陀螺永远指的一个方向呢
哎他这地方就其实就做了一个万向节
而且呢我去测量每一个节点呢旋转的角度
实际上我就知道你这个导弹的话
它的方向是怎么偏的
那么我把这个导弹在沿着时间轴上的
所有的方向偏的这个方向做一个积分
和它的速度在一起积分啊
那我就可以算出什么呢
我其实就可以算出来它的轨迹
所以这个事情真的很了不起啊
就是就用这么简单的一个原理
就比如说我一根空速管测出我的速度
再加上一个我的这个方向的积分
我就能够对我的这个导弹进行导航
当然了
那个时候的误差还是很大的对吧
我飞一个1000km
我能误差个几百米
但是这已经非常了不起了
所以其实你会发现就是游戏
动画里面很多的数学的概念
实际上在真实的世界里面也是非常有用的东西
但是呢万向节呢它其实是有一个小问题的
我们还回归到刚才那个旋转的方程方程啊
你会发现高斯欧拉角的这个表达方式的话呢
当你把它沿着Y轴转了90度之后
你会发现你因为X轴的旋转
它是这样转
对不对
你的Z轴啊
当你沿着Y轴转了一个就是90度之后啊
你的Z轴实际上转的跟X轴是共轴了
那你这你这个时候沿着Z轴做的任何一个旋转
实际上它本身是没有太大意义
只有这两个旋转之间
就是我们叫做阿尔法角和伽马角之间的差值
才有真正的数学意义
这是什么呢
这就是我们经常讲的
就是这个欧拉角的一个退化情况
这个退化情况会导致整个这个模型的旋转
是被锁死了
他就只能沿着那个方向
就就是定死了才转
另外一个呢他会给我们
再比如说我有两个空间上的旋转
我从旋转一到旋转二插值的时候
在这个地方它就会出很大的问题
这也是欧拉角一个很挑战的一个地方
那么其实奥拉贾的话呢还有很多的
虽然它非常有用啊
我们非常符合人的直觉
其实呢它还有这个几个很两两个
我认为是比较难的问题
第一个就是说它非常难以去插值
也就是说我给你一个欧拉角的旋转
就是阿尔法贝塔伽马一对吧
我还有一个阿尔法贝塔伽马二
他俩的差值呢
其实不能简单的用他两个线性上去做
因为你如果大家差一下
你就知道这个值是是错的
第二个的话呢
就是说假设我有两个旋转
一个是阿尔法贝塔伽马
一
有另外一个旋转阿法贝塔伽马二
那他两个假设我按第一次旋转再加叠
加上第二次旋转
就比如说像刚才我举得我们的动画的例子
就是说我这个关节做完了一个旋转
我在这个关节再做一次旋转
这个旋转比较复杂
我在这个方向再转一下
那最后我问这个手手掌面转成什么样子了
你会发现它不能用
简单的
就是说阿尔法
贝塔伽马的一和
阿尔法跟贝塔伽马二两个的数学加在一起
他的这个值是错的
所以其实欧拉角的这个旋转的叫做combination
就是叠加实际上是非常的难
那么第三个呢
也是一个他欧拉角一个最难的问题
就是刚才你会发现我对所有的旋转的表达呢
都是沿着这个就是坐标轴
也就是沿沿着这个xx就是那个X轴Y轴Z轴
但是大家想一想
在真实的世界里面
大部分的旋转
它并不是严格的沿着空间上的XYZ去做的
举个例子
比如说当我的手是这样的时候
诶
我我可能要沿着这个斜向的这个角度
这个角度可能是呃指向空间的-45度啊
这个60度的这个角对吧
我这个时候我做这样的一个旋转
大家发现没有
他其实是很很常见的
那我给定一个定轴
就是任意空间的一个app的一个方向的时候
这个旋转就会变得很很难
所以这其实就是说欧拉角呢
一般来讲我们在给artist的做这个这个
这个编辑的时候
特别是物体的摆放的时候会经常用
但实际上呢在做动画的时候
我们不能用欧拉角
这就是因为欧拉角它本身不好
差值不好去叠加
而且呢也没有办法很难做定轴运算
所以呢这是欧拉角一个很大的场数学的问题
但是它非常符合我们人的自然认知
所以这里面的话呢
就要引出我们大名鼎鼎的这个四元数了对吧
这个四元数真的是非常非常了不起
我我在前几节课一直在讲这样一个概念
就是说我觉得我们的人类
一定要感谢这些非常伟大的数学家
当我们遇到一个真正
我们觉得我们要解决问题的时候
数学家一般在100到200年前
他就已经把数学工具给你准备好了
那哈密尔顿也是一个非常了不起的一个人
这个人应该是个爵士
就是他非常厉害的一件事情是什么呢
就是说他他说那个他的他有次跟这
是他跟他跟他儿子的对话
他说你的哥哥老是在问我说
对于三维空间的这个旋转能不能像负数一样
就非常简单的通过一些数学的RGB
就是那个代数运算
我就能完成这个旋转的叠加
然后呢就是汉密尔顿老先生呢
就每天在早饭散步
通过这个桥的时候
都会在脑子里面去想这个问题
直到有一天他过桥的时候
突然产生了这个伟大的想法
叫四元数的想法
所以他去世之后呢
他的家乡人
就在他那个桥上刻了这个这个这段故事
所以就是他确实是非常了不起的
把这件事情给解决掉
提出了一个叫四元数的概念
那么首先呢什么怎么就理解四元数呢
我们理解四元数之前
首先理解复数还是那个笛卡尔坐标系里面
其实复数它有一个非常好的性质
就是说对于二维空间的任何一个旋转
那么我可以用一个归一化的一个负数值
就是A加BII就是那个负空间的那个轴
那么那么I的平方等于一这样一个定义
我将能够非常优优雅的表表达两个旋转的叠加
大家记得刚才三角函数的公式
对不对
那么你发现A其实就是cos thetb
就是sin theta对吧
你这时候来了一个就是那个那个那个那个A撇
B撇
比如说cos伽马
那个3A伽马
那么那个贝塔加伽马的叠加的话
实际上就可以用下面那个dot production
那个公式就可以完成
而且这个公式的话非常的简单
所以汉密尔顿老先生他就在想说
那对于三维空间的旋转对吧
他一下子多了
就是比二维空间多了两个自由度的话
那我怎么去表达
那我这里面讲了一个非常粗暴的概念啊
就是因为三维空间的旋转
你是有三个轴
二维空间只有一个轴
所以我再加两个维度行不行
你看复数是实数加虚虚部对吧
那我再加两个虚部是不是正好四元数
你看我这个解释听上去是不是很有道理对吧
但实际上呢这个解释是非常不正确的
那个我我我我们前段时间大家在研究的时候
我我我自己也做下去才发现
就是说为什么四元数这东西work的
实际上只有在三维空间的旋转
我用四元数能够表达
你再往上走他就不行了
它实际上是用群论证明了这件事情
就是只有在这种特定的这个这个三维空间的
这个情况下
你的这套数学方法是work的
但这个就非常的复杂
说实话我都没看懂
我记得我当年想研究一下
就是这个为什么这个好像五次以上的方程
就没有这个这个解析解的时候
还冒死去看了一点群论
然后直接就被这个无情的教育了一遍
所以这个地方的话我就不带大家入坑了
因为我也没学会
那我当然素颜四元数的原理的话呢
其实是非常非常的elegant
非常的漂亮的
就是说它首先定义了三个虚无
就是IJK3个序幕
那么我们对于任何一个
就是这个空间上的这个旋转
我们可以尝试用A加BA加C键加DK去表达
所以说大家在游戏引擎里面经常可以看到
CORTANCOTAN指的就是四元数
那这里面的话呢它的三个虚轴呢
它实际上有一个数学规律的
就是I的平方就是负数
那个轴A等于一对吧
J的平方它也不是在十轴上
所以它的平方也等于一
那么K的平方呢也等于一
但这里面优雅的东西来了
就是如果I乘积乘K等于什么呢
哎它也等于一
这个时候就很有意思了
我就问既然我知道I乘积乘K等于一的话
那我就问I乘积等于什么呢
这件事情好像很没有定义
对不对
哎这个时候我们就想起了数学的配平原理
比如说我这里面叫I乘G乘K
我在后面再补个K
然后呢等于-1×2
K就等于负K对不对
那么因为I乘J呢
它的是个K平方
K平方是一
对不对
所以等于说负I界等于负K
所以呢I乘J等于什么呢
等于K
其实你会发现它三个轴都有这样一个交换力
就是I乘J等于K那个J乘K等于I对吧
K乘I也等于J
这就是数学的优美
就是你定义了它的基础算数数学之后
它的整个一个交换和组合
它就全部定义出来了
那么我对他的表达呢
一般我们有两种表达形式
一种就是我们三种吧
一般我们会写成
就
比如说哎我可以写成
就是A加IJK的这个这个虚部形式
有的时候呢我们也会用向量的形式去表达
就是说哎他是一个就是一个一个一列的
四列的向量
有的时候呢我会用一个十步加一个虚部向量
比如说A加V的形式
V本身表达的是BCD也能表达
那么这个时候刚才我们定义了
就是说IJK的他们乘法关系的话
那当我两个CORTI的乘法怎么定义呢
下面你看到那个矩阵了吗
那个矩阵的话是不是看上去很复杂
但是呢它实际上是非常简单的
就是说你得到了一个叫ABCD的
这个这个第一个containing
你讲得到一个EFGH的第一个
第二个CONTAINAN的话
他两个乘法
你可以认为就是说A去乘上那个ED啊
就我或到了看嘛就E吧
E啊不对
应该是AA乘上EFGH的一个所有的虚实部
然后呢他B再一次乘一遍
C在全部乘一遍
D再全部成一遍
然后这里面的话有的时候是I碰到了
有的是I键碰到了
有时候十步和J碰到了
你接下来那一组变换带过去
你发现你得到的就是这个矩阵
这个矩阵其实是非常的简单
那在课上我不展开了
因为我没有办法就依次给大家推导
但是你会发现它你简单运算一下会非常有意思
它的运算就是那样的一个一个矩阵
而这里面的话呢我们就定义了一个东西
就是哎这既然是一个空间上的一个某种轴啊
某种某种某种高高维数字
我们在这个无论在线性代数里面
在还是解析几何里面
我们会定义一个它的膜
对不对
那摩的话最长的定义是什么
就是它的各个维度上的值就是A平方
B平方
C平方
B平方的根号对吧
平方根号也就是A它的膜
那么一个东西呢
它的膜假设等于一的话
我们认为呢它就是一个单位的一个四元数
单位向量
那么这里面的话呢就跟负数一样的
我们引入了一个共轭的概念
就是说把它的虚部全部变成负数对吧
就是负B负C负C负D
那么其实呢这里面这个公式里面少写了一个
就是说如果我这个四元数它本身啊
他是这个normalized
就是说是个单位的四元数的话
那么他的共轭就是它的逆
它的逆是怎么定义的
就是说这个四元数按照刚才那个乘法
乘上另外一个四元数
诶
正好等于一对吧
这个逆其实非常有用
为什么逆就表示了
我假设四元数表达的是旋转的话
它的逆就表示了相反方向的旋转
他这个数学上就是这么定义的
这个概念
大家稍微稍微消化一下
其实呢它的核心原理跟复数非常的相像
但是呢他的乘法
这个矩阵就是稍微计算步数多一点
那么当我有了这样一个四元数的时候
我们就会发现一个很有意思的事情了
就是这个东西呢大家就理解一下
就是说哎我们用四元数如何表达一个欧拉角
那他就这个汉密尔顿老先生
就给出了这样的一个定义
这个呢和大家的理解可能不太一样
就是我们天然的会认为它不应该是不是一堆的
这个阿尔法贝塔伽马的这个sin和sin的组合
对不对
但是呢哈密尔顿给出的公式里面的话呢
哎它都是二分之阿尔法
二分之贝塔
二分之伽马
那为什么他给出了这样的一个矩阵呢
这样呢这样的一个表达呢
是因为当我们用这个CORTI做旋转的时候
比如说我给你任何一个空间上的那个轴也好
坐标也好
它假设它是这个这个这个就是它是BCD吧
这样的一个位置
那么我假设用CORTANA对它进行旋转的时候
你首先要把这个空间上的三维
变成那个就是COTAN的形式
四元数的形式
你把它的实部呢设成零
然后呢你把它的这个就是三个轴
三个轴上的投影写到三个事务里面
就是BICJDK
那你对它进行这个表达之后
你的四元数对它进行旋转的话呢
实际上是用Q在第一个Q就是第一个旋转在前
把那那个就是那个刚才你凑凑出来的那个
四元数夹在中间
然后呢再把他Q的那个me放到后面
记住啊
如果我们再去这个用那个负数去表达
旋转的时候
我只要就是哎
我这个轴承上那个负数就完了对吧
但是呢你在三维空间表达旋转的时候
前后都要加一个
就是你要乘上它
再乘上个力
其实大家如果在学线性代数的时候
这个很像我们线性代数里面的那个SVD分解
对吧
我中间有一个就有一个有一个有个列
向量放在中间
我就他叫那个什么叫做矩阵的秩
还叫什么来着哦
不叫质
叫矩阵的那个什么哎
i can lecture对吧
然后的话呢
两边放了一个这个这个这个标准矩阵
那边放个矩阵的逆
其实非常的像
所以其实四元数
它的很多原理跟矩阵运算是非常非常接近的
那么你把刚才我们在第一节啊
上一次那个就是上一页里面定义的
就是说四元数运算的这个
比如说它的逆是怎么算出来的对吧
逆就是一个标准
就是一个呃呃normalize的四元数的
他的公恶就是他的逆
然后呢
当这个两个四元数的乘法
实际上是一个矩阵的运算
那么其实你的连城就是Q和q-1的连城
你可以依次算过去
就是矩阵的连城吗
那这个时候你就会得到一个非常有意思的公式
就是说我的任何一个空间上的
这个这个这个数字在rotation的时候
我实际上呢那个他做算出来就是一个三
一个3×3的矩阵
这个矩阵因为它有有些项目就消掉了对吧
你只需要知道它的XYZ
那这个就是一个四元数的一个旋转的一个变化
那么这就意味着
就是说你不需要再去算什么sin或sin了
你实际上就是乘上这个矩阵
这个这个任何一个方向
一个角度都可以被旋转起来
这就是非常有道理
非常有意思的一个东西
那么你有了四元数之后
我对他表达一个反向旋转的时候呢
我只要求它的那个那个叫逆就可以了
逆的话我讲过
就是说如果他是个为标准化的四元数的话
你就是把他的IJK
整个反应变成负负数就可以了
是不是非常的简单
而呢那个当我有一个旋转QQ1
我还有一个旋转Q2
那我们假设想把一个点或者一个一个做一个
一个向量
一个方向旋转
按照2Q1Q两次旋转怎么旋转的
其实他那个旋转的四元数呢就是Q1乘Q2
这个里面的话呢就是公式我不展开
但其实你们可以证明这两个事情是等价的
那么还有一个呢比较厉害的
就是说诶
我怎么第一个就是我假设一个方向A方向
V1方向啊
U我要转的方向V怎么办
哎它其实它的原理是非常简单
我先定义一个W就是它的它的那个轴
大家想想差
首先我把那个U乘上个V叉乘个V啊
叉成V就找到他那个向外延伸的那个轴
对不对
你想想大家想看两个方向
是不是定义了一个一个面
这个面的话是不是就可以有一个法向方向
所以呢我们用的右手坐标啊
右手原则的话
我们可以找到一个它往外延伸的那个W的方向
这个时候呢你第一个四表那个第一个四元数
这个四元数呢它的这个就是十部
用这个下面那个公式去表达
就是U点VU点击V加上了开放的这个W点
W加上那个就是那个优点V的这个平方
这个呢就是它的实物
它的虚部是什么呢
就是W本身就W如果你算出来它是XYZ的话
把XYZ把它放到他的那个
就是那个三个虚部里面去
这个课本身就能够表达
这个从U向V的这样的一个旋转
它其实是非常的简单
但这里面的话都是有很多数学推导的
因为这节课的话我不想看
因为当时在我在做这个动画系统的时候
我也不会去过于的把这个公式再证明一遍
基本上这些公式都被这个教科顺序拿过来
我们就可以直接用
而且呢你用完一遍之后
你会发现它用的基本上不会错
那么这里面的话呢就是你有了四元数之后
你想表达
就是说我沿着一个给定轴的旋转
也就非常的简单了
其实呢他的想法也非常的简单
就是说哎你对于任何一个轴
你要去旋转它的时候
我其实定义了一个那个
一个围绕这个轴旋转的四元数
你会发现它的实部就是这个cos呢
它假如你要撞那个theta角嘛
它的实部的话呢就是cos的二分之CA对吧
但是呢它的虚部呢是把那个轴的XYZ
放进去了
但是加上了sin的二分之theta
你用这个四元数去预算的话
你去任何一个向量都可以去转得过去
所以这个你有了这个数学方法的话呢
就是说当我有了空间方向
我从给定了任何一个轴
比如说它是一个不不是轴对齐的轴的话
我其实就可以算出它的旋转了
所以你会发现
就是我们把一个非常复杂的空间的旋转
包括大量的三角函数运算的这个问题的话
变成了一个非常简单的
就是linear egible线性代数的问题
这件事情其实非常的重要
因为同学们如果自己推导一下
就是说假设我全部用欧拉角
我假设有第一组旋转就是阿尔法一贝塔一
伽马一
我有第二组旋转
阿尔法二
贝塔尔C那个伽马二
你把它两次旋转的结果
你想用一个叫阿尔法三
贝塔三
伽马三去表达的话
其实非常的难很复杂
而且可能还有多异性
因为旋转它超过了二派
它不就转了一遍
而且你可以正向旋转
也可以反向旋转
那么这个里面的话呢
就是当你用四元数的时候
它就变得就是一些简单的
没有任何歧义的数学运算
所以CORTA的话
实际上我认为是哈密尔顿对数学的一个
非常关键的贡献
而且这个贡献的话呢
我认为就是当我们进入了计算机时代
当我们进入了这个游戏的虚拟现实期待的时候
我们对其实他在做那个机械
在做钢铁的时候
其实各种轨迹计算的时候
也是非常有用的一个东西
好那这就是我们整个游戏动画的一个数学基础
因为什么呢
因为rotation是动画的最核心的一个
一个一个一个一个元素